the key ends on or destructive disk from
the English dub is a move introduced to
us by Crillon during the Saiyan saga of
Dragon Ball Z and if I might be so bold
the ki an saan is a pretty freakin hella
litte move bro and despite the high
prevalence of regenerative enemies and a
power gap wider than your mom and later
Dragon Ball the ki ends on proved to
have specifically great utility in early
arcs why I'm so glad you asked reason
number one enemies couldn't regenerate
back then it's true animes prior to cell
really couldn't regenerate even Frieza
maintained battle damage throughout the
fight reason number two enemies couldn't
sense energy without the use of a
Scouter seriously this was part of the
reason why power levels were used during
these early arcs bad guys kept relying
on their Scouters and paid for dearly
however and this is the reason I wanted
to make this video the ki an saan when
used in tandem with the underappreciated
defensive moves solar flare a move which
when used blinds its intended target is
pretty much at insta win scenario and as
an angry anime fan I refuse to
acknowledge nor accept the fact that it
would in arguably an objectively make
the fights boring and story
significantly worse because I need my
stupid cartoons to make unrelenting
sense and to never take artistic Liberty
who needs Super Saiyan Goku transforming
for the first time against Frieza when
cruelly can just flash and slice him in
the opening of the fight thus making the
entire arc pointless with that said
let's take a look at five instances
where Crillon should have used the ki an
saan beginning with some minor misses
and building up to a huge missed
opportunity number 5 Krillin and the
androids
[Music]
Oh yep that right there marked the end
of the Kansans usefulness during
dragonball by and large the cans on just
didn't cut it anymore the gap in power
must have been too great or some other
arbitrary power scanning reason I'm
certain and unaware of because lord
knows the power gap between perfect cell
and little o Crillon must be enormous
however despite this brutal end to a
fantastic move we have the entire first
half of Dragon Ball Z to work with and
our first goofed Crillon moment comes
during the Android saga having just
woken up Android 16 17 and 18 find
themselves off against the Z warriors
and Vegeta not sure if he's one of the
boys at this stage of the story is by
either way Vegeta ends up getting
fertilized by a droid 18 single-handedly
until Vegeta is no-handed unstop Android
17 jumps into the fray once the others
realize Vegeta is a danger the final
result of the scuffle is the utter
decimation of the Earth's defenses well
except for Crillon who didn't decide to
jump in at any point to help ignoring
any openings there might have been while
the fight he was taking place for the
cans on two hits mark there's still an
instance where all three androids are
walking away from Crillon with their
backs turned it's already established
neither 17 or 18 consents energy and
Android 16 only cares about Goku at this
point if you ask me that's a huge missed
opportunity for throne
number four crew and the Saiyan saga
okay here's the rundown
Krillin just unveiled to us that he's in
fact capable of throwing an impossibly
sharp laser disc from his pub that can
in fact cut nappa in twain which means
if applied the right way he could quite
literally have saved all of the Warriors
nappa was threatening to kill and has
killed where you ask how about here
only instead of landing one strike on
nappa he uses that damn solar flare that
employ nappa and Vegeta
bing-bang-boom nappa is done and if I'm
being serious he probably could have
taken out Vegeta here too given how
various enemies have reacted to the
solar flare but whatever it's a close
call next one not so much
number three Krillin and dodoria as
you've probably seen so far
much of if not all of the entries on
this list depend on the target not being
able to sense key energy in the early
knocks ah gah go on and krillen being
the first ones from Earth to arrive on
Namek encounter Frieza and his goons
zarab and dodoria slaughtering anime
kyun village they saved tenday from the
ensuing chaos that in their attempted
flee Gohan and krillen are pursued by
dodoria however through what might
appear as quick-thinking Crillon manages
to blind to Doria using the solar flare
allowing go on dende and himself to
escape unharmed
Krillin did think quick but when you
have like five moves in your repertoire
surely slice into dorian half could
never have been easier than right here I
mean he could have saved Vegeta a lot of
work killing tutoria but then how would
Regina learn of his home planets demise
er now I want confusing and lacking
motivation in lieu of specific and
uninteresting fight choreography I
demanded as an angry anime fan number
two Krillin and Roku technically Crillon
never fought or Kubb here but he did
intervene at the last second with Gohan
when Riku himself was about to finish
off Vegeta instead of using the key ins
on Krim decides to dash into harm's way
to kick for Coombes mouth shut I mean
surely staying a safe distance back and
firing a jagged laser disk eliminating
raccoon from the equation entirely would
have been the safest and most efficient
option but then how could Goku have come
in to save the day I guess next number
would Crillon and Frieza Crillon after
being almost killed by freezes horn
entler is he'll fight n day off-screen
and comes to surprise Frieza with a
well-timed Kansa though Frieza dodges it
he does manage to cut off his tail the
process confirming that he can be badly
damaged if caught off-guard by a key
anza but that isn't where this ends
Frieza gives chase to Krillin who
ultimately blinds him with a solar flare
and what does he do he runs away back to
the others to regroup he could have
killed Frieza there and then which yeah
it means no Super Saiyan but also no one
needs to die
who knows maybe Goku got the heart virus
from those filthy yard rats the heart
virus doesn't exist prior to his trip
there
at least in the world of Dragon Ball
Goku seems to be the first to succumb to
its effects I don't know I guess what
I'm saying is Krillin indirectly gave
Goku the heart virus but those are my
top five moments if you can think of
more leave them down below subscribe for
more videos like this and check out my
other stuff I think it's pretty good
have a wonderful day and thank you so
much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]